el coronavirus parece lejos de la
realidad en las playas de copacabana o
en las calles de río donde las
mascarillas y el distanciamiento social
son una rareza pero la pandemia todavía
está latente en brasil este jueves el
país registró más de mil muertes en 24
horas y cerca de 70 mil nuevos casos
brasil ha superado los 7 millones de
casos de kobe 19 pero este número
probablemente sea mayor dada la falta de
pruebas en personas asintomáticas
brasil ha experimentado rebrotes desde
noviembre y existe la preocupación de
que las festividades de fin de año
alimenten los repuntes el gobierno dio a
conocer recientemente su plan de
inmunización aunque ya ha sido criticado
por su falta de detalles y por no tener
una fecha de inicio clara el organismo
de control de salud aún no ha aprobado
ninguna vacuna para uso general
entretanto hay mensajes contradictorios
sobre si su uso será obligatorio este
jueves la corte suprema dictaminó que a
los brasileños se les podría requerir
vacunarse y que aquellos que se nieguen
podrían enfrentar sanciones sin embargo
el presidente ayer bolsonaro ha dejado
muy clara su apreciación si la vacuna se
ofrecerá a todos pero los que no quieran
recibirla no tienen por qué yo no la
recibiré algunos dicen que estoy dando
un mal ejemplo
es imbécil idiota es decir que estoy
dando un mal ejemplo ya sube el virus ya
tengo anticuerpos porque debería vacunar
con frecuencia el presidente ha
minimizado la gravedad del virus también
ha sido criticado por su manejo de la
pandemia más de 184.000 brasileños han
muerto desde que en febrero fue
detectado el primer contagio por kobe 19
en el país